je sais pas ça fait cool et moi même oui
je suis présent monsieur j'ai une
commission à vous faire de la permission
harry lequel me chagrine petit où le
vent les moyens assez je vois le bras
qui me costume et une cravate
steve est toujours une chemise lui niant
le blanc qui vais toujours de pantalon
avec des pulls en versant des eaux
salées je vois le matelassier tapissier
décorateur non judiciaire libraire
papier autsai je ne remets way celui que
mari et son frère et sa soeur avec lux
mouliot non lui la mariée sens faire
avec la filiale ma au ca river seuil je
vois qu'ici est celui qui est évoluera
communion de nourrice ou le fils à ses
roueries non lui avaient pas pu
maintenir il avait envoyé son frère aîné
où le cadet ya moyen celui qui met
jamais intimider les pénis ali est à la
fois celui qui s'est associé avec riton
le marchand des quatre saisons
mais non il avait pris la paire à son
compte avec blood comme comptable l'on
doit le représentant des vins et
spiritueux nie en bloc dans l'ancien
chanteur pastel mirallas lequel miralles
miralles des ptt ou miralles la balance
qui tapait la concacaf et la brusque a
su se libérer se rendre au sri lanka ue
qui faisait les notes du banquier local
faille où le père ou le fils aîné vers
une veuve qui n'était toujours servi les
vignes les villes et villes et vie c'est
un nom qui me dit quelque chose
lequel les inédits qui travaillait chez
voo rire se sont polis boîtier oublier
les villes hôtes plus ici au palais de
justice dans les villes mais dès qu'ils
passent et le tailleur je suis libéral
ancien apprenti vidal d'alger connu
vidalon un ancien joueur de football qui
faisait rien le matin qui se reposaient
l'après midi et qu'il allait pas
l'entraînement le soin taxi dans le taxi
vous confondez pas avec charlie briguer
ce que son père l'avait drogué villa
vous arrivez à compter de ce rsa le
boulanger mais nominal qui faisait le
taxi qui l'a 24 115 à 104 bleu au noir
et gris avec le toit bleu bleu clair ou
bleu foncé le ciel qui tirait sur le
verre et le gars est où l'une voulait
prouver
il avait des enfants oui des cartes eye
fi une fille c'est une scic roman et si
une fille une fille pour l'appeler la
capitale
elle était mariée oui avec laquelle
monsieur henri celui qui ma voix à 80 il
faut des contrôleurs au cinéma rialto
estime wulf et voilà oui savoir si vous
avez connu à nommer dupont dupont alors
lequel dupont celui qui faisait un
glacier obara synthes le qui
travaillaient cadavres de chiens siro
mais reste celui qui était contre l'euro
s'est fait rare à celui qui était
contrôleur au t1
celui qui travaille à des gaspards du
juba celui qui t'a pas ce gouvernement y
avait du port